game review game review
my name is Caleb Ben me and welcome back
to game review today I'm gonna be going
over a game from the young Jeffrey Zhang
in the Tata Steel Masters Tournament of
course this tournament is nearing its
close I probably will be over by the
time this video airs but Jeffery having
a little bit of an up-and-down
tournament some wins some losses and
we'll see how this game went for him
here today he was playing the Russian
Vladislav Artemyev and in the game he
chose d4 and went for a Queens gambit
Artemyev chose c6 going for the Slav
Geoffrey played Knight f3 Knight f6 and
Knight c3 just developing both the
Knights it's one of the main main lines
and it gives white kind of a lot of
options here black chooses a6 with some
ideas of playing an early b5 here after
a 6 white usually has the option to play
this move c5 taking advantage of the
weakened dark squares for black however
Geoffrey chooses a much simpler approach
simply playing III like I said keeping
things flexible this is the way Geoffrey
kind of him handled this opening and now
black does something a little bit
offbeat generally black expands with b5
keeping in mind this a 6 push you know
keeping the ideas consistent instead in
this game we see this move g6 and this
is a pretty committal move actually it's
not one that I'm often a fan of it's
committing this Bishop to this diagonal
which for the moment is remaining closed
and so now black is committing to
putting this Bishop here and by doing so
he's kind of committing to trying trying
to open up this diagonal just not always
the easiest thing to accomplish white
plays Bishop e2 black continues with
Bishop g7 castles castles notably this
Bishop does not go to d3 because this
Bishop might actually just meet it on
the f5 square and from d3 you're really
just looking at nothing here with h7 and
g6 solidly defending this diagonal so e2
is the better square in this case
Jeffery continues with a four Artemyev
responds in kind with a five and you see
this move from black a five because he
wants to prevent white from playing a
five instead you can imagine a Bishop g4
and after move like Queen b3 hitting
this pawn rook a seven classic slob
maneuver let's move a five can really
hamper the entire black Queens sight
here so we see a5 from black keeping
that idea off the books
now after C takes d5 and C takes d5 you
see what I mean by black having
committed to this bishop here once you
see the strain change in structure with
C takes d5 its becomes very very
difficult to open up this Bishop White
has good control over this a five square
for the moment if he doesn't manage to
to force this diagonal openings he's
gonna have serious problems
Geoffrey chose a very nice way to finish
development with b3 this bishop of
course the the notably undeveloped piece
for white he finds an open diagonal for
it though nice see six bishop a3 is now
hitting a weakness on e7 Bishop g4 is
blacks choice like I said he needs to
shake loose this a five square so this
Bishop can can kind of shine Geoffrey
doesn't really give them the chance
though you know a weaker player might
continue with move like rook c1 which is
a fine move but now their ideas of
capturing this piece playing the move
rook e8 and expanding very very quickly
in the center here instead though Knight
e5 is Jeffrey's choice not allowing him
to trade off this LightSquared Bishop
for a piece that defends the e5 square
and now black is committed into going
into a very forced series of exchanges
here technically you can play move like
Bishop e6 but then you've wasted some
time and n white should have an edge so
black plays the most natural way which
is to simply accept all of the exchanges
here and after D takes e5 94 is the only
serious move here and now white can take
off this night as well and it looks like
a lot of things have been liquid
and I should be doing okay the structure
is symmetrical he's going to be taking
this pawn on e5 but the fact is the
white pieces are just coming into play a
hair faster than the black pieces here
and because of that black has some very
very concrete problems and so maybe
black was a little bit a little bit
hasty and going for all of these
exchanges going for this forest line
here cuz Jeffrey really managed to prove
an advantage and move Queen c4 is how he
did it
we can see for hitting this pawn on e4
hitting this bishop or hitting this pawn
on e7 and most importantly freeing up
this d1 square for a rook to shake loose
this defender of the Queen here perhaps
the most natural way to play was the way
that blacks should have played this move
Bishop takes e5 but already black still
has some problems here and the move rook
d1 is very natural and perhaps the best
and after Queen b6 white kind of has
this pick of pawns to pick up here
perhaps even the move rook d7 could be
quite problematic and in all of these
lines white just has a little bit of an
edge in activity and ends up with a
slightly better endgame in the game
black chose not to go in for these
add-in games instead going for a
different endgame with this move Queen
d3 this move forces the Queen's off the
board which Geoffrey accepts and after
rook d1 now you see Bishop e5 and York
takes d3 and this is the problem with a
lot of openings that that look like this
for for black here you know you get this
symmetrical structure and it feels like
you should have equalized it feels like
things should be okay but the white
pieces somehow just have a little bit of
edge in in time due to that first move
and here it's it's no different black
still has problems to solve this pawn on
e7 is hanging and the rook is already on
the open file that's kind of two
advantages that that white has here in
the position and Geoffrey does a very
nice job of turning this into a concrete
material edge we
the rook FDA from black Jeffry plays
very principal Eve he doesn't want to
give his opponent the open file so he
supports this rook with her up d1 not
capturing on d8 although that would have
also given him a nice edge we see rook
takes d3 Rick takes d3 rook c8 and then
Geoffrey took on e7 and the game was
over just kidding
Geoffrey plays g4 not hanging back rank
mate Bishop f6 no black had to defend
this pawn at some point now rook d5 is
Geoffrey's move and this move is
annoying it's just it's annoying how
this little little tiny advantage in
time is being turned into something so
concrete and something so problematic
for black this pot is attacked on a5
black defends it and here a nasty move
might have been g5 for Geoffrey it's
definitely worth considering of course
you can't really move this bishop
because this pawn will hang you do have
this Intermezzo though e 6 and then
Bishop d8 would defend b6 which is
probably why Geoffrey didn't want to go
for this but it turns out this endgame
is still quite favorable for white
instead of g5 Geoffrey chooses rook b5
immediately also very very strong and
now the problem with playing move like
rooks c6 to defend is now this g5 move
will come there's no e6 intermezzo and
this pawn will hang that's why black
chose this move Bishop h4 going for
counter play all along the second-ranked
himself Geoffrey simply picks up his
free pawn and after rook c2 he tries to
tie everything together with this move
f3 which is a very nice move this Bishop
comes to f2 check King H 1 black regains
his pawn for a moment but after a check
and King g7 white takes an e pawn and
now white is simply up up a solid pawn
and all that's left to do is consolidate
and win the endgame of course black does
have some pressure around this King and
there are a couple weaknesses to look
out for but Geoffrey handles it very
very well black actually starts with
this move f5 and this move was aimed at
loosening up a couple more pawns in the
white camp
this move always comes with its
downsides in the game Jeffrey chose rook
b7 pointing out the fact that this pawn
no longer defends the king this King
comes back to g8 now after G takes f 5
and G takes at 5 this writ can come to
b5 and it turns out black might have
just weakened his own pawns rather than
rather than the white pawns here I'm not
sure how I feel about this whole f5 idea
from him now black pushes with f4 trying
to create some more threats around the
White King supporting this bishop as
well
Geoffrey simply picks up another pawn on
a5 and now the end game is pretty
hopeless this King comes to f7 but at
the end of the day it's not enough to
compensate for this Queen side majority
bishop age 4 rook be 2 hits this pawn
white simply defends Bishop d4 a5 and
now we see the pawns ever so slowly
start to roll up the board a few more
checks a few more maneuvering moves
especially comes to d8 to defend this a
pawn kind of nice long-range defense
black goes after this F pawn but it's
too little too late after Bishop h4 this
pawn is actually untouchable due to a
very funny rook trap so the row comes
back to a2 we repeat once so it comes
back to f2 now we see rip d1 now if you
were to capture this pawn you're simply
not in time to stop the the Queen side
pawns so we see rook b2 instead open up
G to rook be 2 instead it should be 7
defense or a2 now Bishop c5 always
transposing into winning end games if
you're not careful
rook C 1 and this pawn is too powerful
so instead we see h4 this Bishop comes
to d4 rook a four and once again a lot
of moves being played here but the
result was never in doubt rook a 1 once
again giving black the opportunity to
transpose into a more clear endgame but
the fact is this end game is simply
losing as we soon find out
white plays King g1 keeping an eye on
this epon not letting it get too far and
after rook d4 King f1 guards the e2
square rook d2 and now Geoffrey had it
all calculated out a6 rook takes h2 King
g1 is his choice
Rick d2 now a7ii to Geoffrey gets a
queen after this check artemyev gets a
queen but the downside for black is
white gets to move ah it's just kind of
the theme of the game here why it's
always just one step ahead and that is
the case here as well despite the
material being technically even this
king is super exposed and white gets a
turn to go and try to checkmate it which
he does queen c6 check King h5 Queen c5
check King aged 6 and now it's the
simple step ladder mate that we're all
familiar with or the major pieces Corral
this King up the board and after Queen
c7 check black went ahead and resigned
here of course no way to stop the
checkmate or at the very least no way to
avoid giving up a full Queen and so this
is a very well played game by Geoffrey
actually taking advantage of that one
extra tempo that he had keeping his
activity and turning it into a concrete
advantage and then showing some very
nice endgame technique never letting his
opponent back into the game and ending
with a victory well that just about does
it
thank you very much for joining me on
this episode of my name is Caleb Denby
and I'll see you in the next episode